THIS. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
IT'S MAY FOURTH AND MAY THE
FOURTH BE WITH YOU ALL. I HAVE.
AND BECAUSE IT'S MAY FOURTH IT'S
TIME FOR ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE THREE OF. WE ARE
HAVING AN IN PERSON HEARING
HEARING. CAPITAL OF ROOM FOR
FORTY FOUR WILL BE VOTING ON
PREVIOUSLY HEARD PROPOSALS TODAY
AND HEARING A FEW NEW PROPOSALS
THIS MAY BE A RELATIVELY SHORT
MEANING COMPARED TO THOSE THAT
YOU'RE USED TO. THOSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN PERSON MAY DO SO WHEN
WE OPENED PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THE HEARING. AFTER LOSING
COMMITTEE WROTE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM HAVE SPOKEN WE WILL ALLOW
PHONE TESTIMONY. AND THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING THIS HEARING
ONLINE. THE PHONE NUMBER IS YOU
ALL IF YOU'RE HERE IN THE ROOM
YOU SHOULD HAVE MEMORIZED THIS
BY NOW- 877-692-8957 OF COURSE
IF YOU'RE IN THE ROOM YOU DON'T
NEED THE PHONE NUMBER THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR AGAIN THAT
PHONE NUMBER IS 877-692-8957 AND
THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR. FOUR FOUR.
WE IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY UP. ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO NINE NINE. AND ONE OF THE
FRIENDLY STAFF MEMBERS THERE
WILL ASSIST YOU ASSUMING THEY'VE
HAD THEIR COFFEE ALREADY. THOSE
TESTIFYING WILL HAVE UP TO ONE
MINUTE TO SPEAK. WE ENCOURAGE
THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HEARING
PLEASE SEND YOUR WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO BUDGET SUB THREE
THAT'S NUMERAL THREE BUDGET SUB
THREE. AT ASM DOT C. A. DOT G.
OVIH. WITHOUT LET'S BEGIN WITH A
ROLL CALL THIS MAY BE A FIRST
FOR THE C. HERE THAT WERE
ACTUALLY- GOING TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
MEETING LET'S GO. HELLO HERE
SENATE HERE FRIEDMAN. MULLIN
PATTERSON YEAH RIVAS HERE SMITH
HERE FORMER PRESIDENT. GREAT
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH THE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR WE HAVE A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE ITEMS
FOR CONSIDERATION ON THAT
CALENDAR- THEY'RE LISTED ON THE
AGENDA FOR YOUR REFERENCE BUT
ALL BREAK OUT THE- THE MOTION SO
THAT WE- GET THIS DONE AND
RELATIVELY SMOOTH FASHION- BUT
BEFORE WE VOTE ON ITEMS WILL THE
ITEMS THAT ALL IDENTIFY- I'D
LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT ON ISSUE
EIGHTY ONE- WELL WE ARE. GOING
TO APPROVE THIS PROPOSAL TODAY
IF THINGS GO THE WAY THEY SHOULD
GO- OUT WE MUST CONTINUE TO LEAD
THE CLEAN ENERGY TRANSITION BY
RELYING ON RELIABLE ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES AND
UNFORTUNATELY AND- THE MONEY HAS
ALREADY BEEN SPENT ON THIS ITEM
AND- NON RENEWABLE TECHNOLOGY-
GENERATORS HAVE BEEN. PURCHASED
WE SHOULD BE- BECAUSE WE SHOULD
BE FUNDING RENEWABLE ENERGY AND
BATTERY STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES TO
HELP DEAL WITH OUR ENERGY
CHALLENGES THAT ARE CAUSED AND
EXACERBATED BY CLIMATE CHANGE
AND NOT RELY ON FOSSIL FUELS
THAT FUEL CLIMATE CHANGE. I'M SO
WELL WITH THAT- A COMMENT TO AND
I DO HOPE THAT TO THE NEXT TIME
PURCHASES LIKE THIS- A OCCUR THE
EIGHT ARE WITH SUSTAINABLE.
TECHNOLOGIES RENEWABLE
TECHNOLOGIES- WE WILL. TAKE UP
OUR FIRST VOTE TO APPROVE AS
BUDGETED THE FOLLOWING VOTE ONLY
ISSUES. ALSO SET THEM SLOWLY FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO MIGHT BE TAKING
NOTES BUT THEY ARE IN THE
AGENDA- SO THIS VOTE FIRST VOTE
WOULD BE TO APPROVE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH TWENTY TO. TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY FIVE THROUGH
THIRTY SIX THIRTY NINE THROUGH.
434-062-5350. FIVE SIXTY ONE
SIXTY TWO SIXTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE.
SIXTY SEVEN THROUGH EIGHTY
EIGHTY SIX THROUGH EIGHTY EIGHT
. NINETY NINETY TWO NINETY THREE
NINETY NINE ONE HUNDRED. ONE OH
TWO FOR ONE- FOR. ONE OF SIXTY
ONE FOURTEEN AND ONE TWENTY
SEVEN THROUGH ONE THIRTY THREE.
MAY I HAVE A MOTION ON THOSE
ITEMS ONLY PLEASE. I HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND WILL PROCEED
WITH THE ROLL CALL PLEASE WELL.
I SENATE HI FRIEDMAN. MULLIN
PATTERSON RIVAS I- THE SECOND
VOTE WOULD BE TO APPROVE AS
BUDGETED THE FOLLOWING VOTE ONLY
ISSUES. TWENTY THREE TO TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY NINE THREE THIRTY FOUR
THIRTY SEVEN THROUGH THIRTY
EIGHT. 444-055-4552 SIXTY. I'M
SORRY FIFTY SIX ZERO SIXTY
SHOULD CLEAN MY GLASSES. LET ME
BEGIN- OVER AGAIN- YOU SHOULD
ALL BE ROUNDING UP. TWENTY THREE
TO TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY NINE TO THIRTY
FOUR. 372-384-0440. 554-563-6060. THREE SIXTY SIX EIGHTY ONE
THROUGH EIGHTY FIVE. EIGHTY NINE
NINETY EIGHT ONE OH ONE ONE OH
FIVE AND ONE FIFTEEN THROUGH ONE
TWENTY SIX. MAY I HAVE A MOTION
PLEASE. WE'LL THANK YOU LET'S
HAVE A ROLL CALL VOTE HELLO HI
SENATE HI FRIEDMAN HI MULLIN.
PATTERSON RIVAS HI SMITH NO. TWO
BE A PROBLEM YES. WILL A I BRING
UP THE VOTE ONLY ITEM SO- OF THE
FIRST GROUP OF ITEMS DO I NEED
TO IDENTIFY. OUR FIRST VOTE WE
WILL NOW TO ADD ONS FRIEDMAN.
MULLIN. M. WE WILL. HOLD THE-
THAT OPEN FOR ADD ONS BOTH OF
THOSE. MOTIONS WILL PROCEED NOW
TO ISSUE ONE. WHICH IS THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE DISCUSSING
THE ENERGY RESOURCES PROGRAMS
ACCOUNT OR URBAN. STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT RELIEF TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WE HAVE OUR PANELISTS
TODAY WELCOME- MISTER BOWMAN.
FROM THE S. C. E. C. AT- OTHER
WILL HAVE- SPEAKER FROM ALEJO
AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GOOD
MORNING. FORMICA I. TRY THAT
RIGHT. WANT TO TAP THE MIKE HE
SAID NOT TO TOUCH IT I THINK
IT'S WORTHWHILE I MUST ADMIT
OKAY. YES I FIXED IT RIGHT REYES
DON'T FORGET I HAVE CONTROL.
INDEED RELEASE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ALL THANK YOU CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS DREW
BOWEN AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND AS TEACHER
POINTED OUT THIS ITEM IS ABOUT
OUR PRIMARY FUNDING ACCOUNT THE
ENERGY RESOURCES PROGRAM ACCOUNT
FOR. URBAN IT'S IN A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT IN WE'RE HERE TODAY TO-
DESCRIBE THE WAYS IN WHICH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ATTEMPTS TO
FIX IT- THE DEMAND FOR OUR
SERVICES HAS BEEN GROWING SO
OVER THE LAST DECADE THE
LEGISLATURES APPROVED OVER
SEVENTY POSITIONS FOR THE ENERGY
COMMISSION IN EUROPE ACCOUNT.
AND AT THE SAME TIME THE
REVENUES THAT THE ACCOUNT IS
GENERATING ARE. STEADILY
DECLINING. AND THE REASON
THEY'RE DECLINING IS WHAT WE
LIKE TO CHARACTERIZE AS- US
BEING VICTIMS OF OUR OWN SUCCESS
THERE ARE TWO PRINCIPAL DRIVERS
THE FIRST IS BEHIND THE METER
GROWTH. IN SO WE'RE UP TO TWELVE
GIGAWATTS NOW OF BEHIND THE
METER CHIEFLY SOLAR SOME WIND UP
SOME OF THE RESEARCH BUT IT'S
BUT CHEAPLY SOURCE OR UP TO
TWELVE TWELVE GIGAWATTS- VERY
LARGE NUMBER. THE SECOND FACTOR
IS CONSERVATION AND SO THE
ENERGY COMMISSION ADOPTS I THINK
IS MOST OF YOU KNOW A BOTH
BUILDING CODE- OUT REGULATIONS
THAT REQUIRE THAT CERTAIN
EFFICIENCY MEASURES BE EMBEDDED
IN AND NEWLY BUILT BUILDINGS OR
MAJOR ADDITIONS. AND SECOND WE-
ADOPT REGULATIONS THAT REGULATE
THE MANNER IN WHICH OCT
ELECTRONICS AND OTHER
ELECTRICITY CONSUMING. PRODUCTS
CONSUMER ELECTRICITY AND THE-
APPROACHES TO IS TO REDUCE THEM
THROUGH THROUGH ABOUT
TECHNOLOGICAL IMPROVEMENTS.
THESE TWO FACTORS TOGETHER. HAVE
BEEN CONSPIRING TO REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF METERED ELECTRICITY
WHICH IS GREAT FOR CALIFORNIA
pBUT IT'S BEEN NOT SO GREAT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION'S BUDGET. AND SO JUST
GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE THE- THAT
THE TELEVISION- PLANTS
REGULATIONS WE ADOPTED SOME
YEARS AGO- WE ESTIMATE SAVE EACH
CONSUMER ABOUT FIFTY FIVE
DOLLARS PER YEAR PER TELEVISION
SO THE MODEST INCREASE IN THE
COST OF THE TELEVISION BORN. ARE
CAUSED BY THE IT THAT THE
CHANGES THAT NEED TO BE MADE IN
THE MANUFACTURING PROCESS GET
PAID FOR VERY VERY QUICKLY IN IN
A DECADE WHICH IS WHAT WE
ESTIMATE THE AVERAGE TV'S LIFE
IS THE CONSUMER GETS BACK FIVE
FIFTY DOLLARS. THAT'S ONE
EXAMPLE TO PRETTY PRETTY GOOD
ONE THERE'S OTHERS WITH BATTERY
CHARGERS WITH COMPUTERS AND SO
FORTH BUT AGAIN THESE TWO
FACTORS BEHIND THE METER
CONSUMPTION THAT DOESN'T GET.
THE URBAN CHARGE APPLIED TO IT
AND CONSERVATION HAVE DEPRESSED
THE OB. ROSS THE REVENUES FOR
CALIFORNIA. SO THAT IS OUR
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT SO WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING- IS TO- MAKE MAKE
THREE CHANGES AND BY THE WAY WE
HAVE WE HAVE OVER THE YEARS
WORKED VERY HARD TO REDUCE
EXPENDITURES WE'VE SHIFTED THE
LAST SEVERAL BUDGET CYCLES
THIRTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
OFF OF HER BY. ABOUT TWENTY OF
THAT IS- SHIFTS TO OTHER FUNDS
ABOUT SIXTEEN OF IT IS SIXTEEN
TO SEVENTEEN OF IT IS ACTUAL.
REAL CUTS AND- JUSTGIVING A
FAIRLY RECENT EXAMPLE WE MOVED
TO A NEW. FLOOR SPACE AND WE ARE
SAVING OVER A MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR READ. WE ALSO- JUST AFTER
THE PANDEMIC A COUPLE MONTHS
AFTER MARCH TWENTY TWENTY I GOT
RID OF ALL OF OUR LAND LINES AND
BOUGHT UP SELF OF THE FLIP
PHONES BASICALLY FOR ALL OF OUR
STAFF. AND THE NET IS ABOUT A
TWO HUNDRED AND LITTLE OVER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR SAVINGS AS A CONSEQUENCE OF
NOT HAVING LIMITS ANYMORE. SO
WE'RE VERY FRUGAL WE TRY TO
MANAGE YOUR MONEY VERY CAREFULLY
NEVERTHELESS WE'RE WE'RE STUCK
IN THIS POSITION SO WE HAVE A
PROPOSAL THAT HAS THREE PARTS
THE FIRST. IS TO RAISE THE
STATUTORY CAPS RIGHT NOW THIS
THE CAP IS AT THREE TENTHS OF
THE MIDDLE SO POINT ZERO ZERO
ZERO THREE. CENTS PER KILOWATT
HOUR CONSUMED BY CONSUMERS. AND
WILL PROPOSE RAISING THAT TO
POINT ZERO ZERO ZERO FIVE FIVE.
IN THE WAY THE STATUTORY
MECHANISM WORKS IS EVERY
NOVEMBER THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION IS EMPOWERED TO
ADJUST THAT RATE COULD BE UP IT
COULD BE DOWN- IT'S DONE IN A
PUBLIC MEETING AND WE'VE DONE IT
A COUPLE TIMES OVER THE YEARS.
WHICH HAS RAISED THAT LEVEL THAT
WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW TO THE
STATUTORY CAP SO THAT'S ONE
INCREASE THE CAP. THE SECOND IS
TO TAX TAG THAT CAP TO
INFLATION. THE SENATE COMMISSION
REPORT BY THE SENATE OFFICE OF
RESEARCH THAT FOUND THAT HAD
THAT HAPPENED BACK IN THE
SEVENTIES WHEN WE WERE CREATED.
WE WOULD ABOUT ABOUT POINT FIVE
FIVE POINT ZERO ZERO ZERO FIVE
FIVE NOW- SO WE THINK TO AVOID
COMING IN HERE AGAIN IN THE
FUTURE THIS IS A SENSIBLE SECOND
MOVE AND THEN FINALLY. BECAUSE
BEHIND THE METER TODAY UP TILL
TODAY HAS NOT BEEN. CONTRIBUTING
TO THE- BUT SURCHARGE WE ARE
RECOMMENDING THE BUDGET THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET RECOMMENDS
THAT WE- INCLUDE BEHIND THE
METER- IN IN THE CALCULATION.
INTERESTING WHAT THIS MEANS IN
REAL DOLLARS. THE BUT I
SURCHARGE GENERATES ABOUT SIXTY
NINE SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR LATELY. AND THAT TRANSLATES
INTO A HEAP AND APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTEEN CENTS. PER MONTH PER. A
PAIR. IF THAT'S THE THAT THAT'S
AVERAGE IF YOU'RE MAJOR RIGHT-
MAJOR CONSUMER OF ELECTRICITY
YOUR FIGURES GONNA BE
SUBSTANTIALLY HIGHER BUT BUT
THAT'S THE AVERAGE ACROSS ALL
OUR CLASSES SO CLOSING WE THINK
THIS IS AN EXCELLENT INVESTMENT
FOR CALIFORNIA WE ARE NOT AWARE
OF TOO MANY STATE AGENCIES THAT
CAN SAY THE INVESTMENTS IN WHAT
WE DO RETURN ACTUAL MONEY TO
THOSE WHO ARE MAKING THE
INVESTMENTS NAMELY THAT THE RATE
PAYERS IN CALIFORNIA BY VIRTUE
OF THE CONSERVATION I DESCRIBED-
AND S WE THINK THIS IS A SOUND
INVESTMENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. THANK YOU- WE HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS FOR YOU BUT FIRST I
SHOULD OBSERVE THAT I THINK THAT
THE US CPI- INCREASE THAT YOU'RE
PROPOSING IS MUSIC TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENEFITS- ERRORS BECAUSE
THAT'S SOMETHING HE'S BEEN
PUSHING FOR A- ALL YEAR- LET'S
SAY HRE FROM- THE- DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND THEN THE OHIO
PLEASE. YEAH I THINK. IMMA NOW
BEEN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THE-
BUT SHE'D BE OUT REALLY A
PROPOSED SOLUTION TO A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT WITHIN THIS
FUND THAT'S EXISTED FOR A FAIR
AMOUNT OF YEARS NOW THAT WE'VE
RETURNED- I THINK. FOR AS LONG
AS I'VE BEEN AT FINANCE- SO WERE
QUESTIONING THIS THROUGH THE
BUDGET- AND I THINK THE CHAIRS
ARE THE DIRECTOR SUMMED IT UP
WELL SO. YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS ROSS BROWN AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I
WANT TO BEGIN OUR COMMENTS BY
SAYING THAT WE DO AGREE THAT
THERE IS CURRENTLY A- DEFICIT IN
THE FUND AND THAT LEGISLATIVE
ACTION MIGHT BE NEEDED- IN THE
COMING YEARS TO PREVENT
INSOLVENCY FOR THE FOR THE FUNDS
HOWEVER WE DO THINK THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF IMPORTANT FACTORS FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER WHEN
EVALUATING THIS PROPOSAL IN THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE OF THE PROBLEM
IN THE FUNDS ONE OF THEM IS MORE
SHORT TERM AND ONE OF THEM IS
LONGER TERM. ON THE SHORT TERM
SIDE OF THINGS- FIRST
ADMINISTRATION PROJECTS THAT THE
FUND WILL GO AND WILL NOT GOING
SOLVE ONCE UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE SO THAT'S A FEW
YEARS FROM NOW AS A RESULT IN
IMMEDIATE ACTION TO ADDRESS THE
DEFICIT IS NOT ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY THIS YEAR- IT'S ALSO
WORTH NOTING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT PROVIDED
A DETAILED PROJECTION OF THE
FUNDING CONDITION- FIVE YEARS
OUT WHICH- HAS BEEN DONE IN
PREVIOUS- IN PREVIOUS YEARS AND
SO THERE STILL IS SOME
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT- WHEN THE FUND
WILL GO INSOLVENT WITHOUT THAT
ADDITIONAL DETAIL. OF THE SECOND
ON THE LONG TERM SIDE OF THINGS-
THE MAGNITUDE OF THE STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT OVER THE LONG RUN IS
ALSO UNCLEAR- THIS IS BECAUSE
REVENUES ARE- AT LEAST
ELECTRICITY SALES ARE PROJECTED
TO GROW- UNDER THE ENERGY
COMMISSION'S PROJECTIONS GOING
FORWARD DUE TO STATE EFFORTS
AROUND ELECTRICAL
ELECTRIFICATION OF BUILDINGS AND
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR YOU
CAN SEE SORT OF- SOME OF THE
ENERGY COMMISSION'S PROJECTIONS
ON PAGE SEVEN THERE'S A FIGURE
ON PAGE SEVENTY SEVEN OF THE-
AGENDA THAT. PROVIDES A KIND OF
A MID CASE AND HIGH CASE AND SO
AS A RESULT THE DEGREE TO WHICH
A LONG TERM INCREASE IN THE
SURCHARGE RATE IS NEEDED IT'S
UNCLEAR AS RATHER. IN IN SALES.
PARTIALLY UP OFF SOME OF. SOME
OF THE DEFICIT. SO WITH THAT
CONTEXT IN MIND WE DO THINK THE
LEGISLATURE HAS SOME DIFFERENT
OPTIONS THAT IT COULD CONSIDER
ON THIS PROPOSAL- ONE OF THOSE
OPTIONS IT COULD CONSIDER
REJECTING THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL THIS YEAR BUT ADOPTING
AND SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE THAT REQUIRES THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON THE STRUCTURAL DEFICIT
NEXT YEAR. INCLUDING A
PROJECTION OF SOME OF THE LONG
TERM REVENUES AND COSTS THIS
WOULD BE SIMILAR TO PREVIOUS
YEARS THERE WAS A SIMILAR
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED AND COULD
ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE TO.
CONTINUE TO MONITOR MONITOR
CONDITION OF THE FUND AND TAKE
ACTION AS NECESSARY IN THE
FUTURE. IF THE LEGISLATURE DOES
WANNA- MAKE CHANGES THIS YEAR TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE- IT
COULD CONSIDER ADOPTING CERTAIN
ASPECTS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL- BUT REJECTING OTHERS
SO FOR EXAMPLE. IN OUR VIEW
EXTENDING THE SURCHARGE TO
BEHIND THE METER CONSUMPTION
COULD HELP ENSURE THAT- THE
REVENUES COLLECTED MORE
EQUITABLY EQUITABLY ACROSS ALL
ENERGY CONSUMERS. AND WE ALSO
THINK THAT TIME THE SURCHARGE
TO- INFLATION IS A REASONABLE
STRATEGY TO ENSURE. THAT FUTURE
REVENUE WAS SUFFICIENT TO PAY
FOR GROWTH AND BASS LINE COSTS
SUCH AS GROWTH IN SALARIES AND
BENEFITS FOR CC STAFF. IN BOTH
CASES WE THINK THERE'S A PRETTY
CLEAR POLICY IN FISCAL RATIONALE
FOR THOSE CHANGES. I LEGISLATURE
COULD ALSO CONSIDER OTHER
OPTIONS TO REDUCE THINGS ON THE
SPENDING SIDE OF SUCH AS
SHIFTING- THERE'S ABOUT ONE
POINT THREE MILLION- IN COSTS
RELATED TO THE EPIC PROGRAM THAT
COULD BE SHIFTED ONTO. THE FUND
THAT TYPICALLY PAYS THOSE- THOSE
COSTS SO- THAT LEGISLATURE HAS
TOUCHED THE SUM UP THE-
MAGNITUDE OF THE OF THE ISSUE
HERE THERE'S KIND OF SOME SHORT
TERM OR LONG TERM
CONSIDERATIONS- AND THE
LEGISLATURE. THE DIFFERENT
OPTIONS THAT COULD PLAY TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE SO HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
WELL LET ME BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND- I
JUST KIND OF DOVE TAIL IN THE
COMMENT I MADE AND- PERHAPS.
HOPEFULLY NOT STEALING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENEFITS THUNDER HERE
BUT- WE HEAR WE HAVE A- AN
AGENCY THAT'S PROPOSING A CAR- A
REGULAR COST OF LIVING INCREASE-
HOW OFTEN- IN PROPOSALS LIKE
THIS. IS THAT INCLUDED SO THAT
WE DON'T HAVE TO COME BACK AND
IT'S- PLEASE AND WHY IS THAT
MORE NOT MORE OF A- GENERALLY
ADOPTED POLICY- ON WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION. I CAN'T SPEAK
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION ON THAT
PROPOSAL BUT AND NOW WE ARE
LOOKING AT CPI AT THREE THESE
PROPOSALS OFFICE STATES COME
FORTH HERE AT THE APPETITE WITH
HER FAT- HAPPY KIND OF TO TAKE
THAT BACK AND LOOK AT. OUR
OVERALL APPROACH TO INTRODUCING
CBI TO SUCH PROPOSALS THAT-
WHERE IT MAKES SENSE
PARTICULARLY WITH OPERATING AN
OPERATING ACCOUNT FOR THE ENERGY
COMMISSION WOULD HAVE.
CONSIDERED IT ESPECIALLY ON THE
BASIS OF A LEGISLATIVE
RECOMMENDATION FROM- YOUR OWN.
BODY SENATE OFFICE OF RESEARCH
THANK YOU ALL THAT- MISTER
BENNETT TO COMMENT FURTHER ON
THAT IF HE IF HE'D LIKE TO BUT-
OF THE LEASE FOR MY PART I
THINK. IT WOULD BE GREAT TO-
HEAR BACK HOW WE CAN BROADEN THE
APPLICABILITY OF CPI INCREASES-
ON A VARIETY OF SITUATIONS THAT
MIGHT BE SIMILAR TO THIS AT
LEAST- WE- THAT- MISTER BALL AND
WHAT. DO WE- EXPECT TO RECEIVE A
DETAILED OF THE FUND CONDITION
FOR TWENTY THREE AND BEYOND- YOU
MAY CHOOSE IF YOU WANT TO
RESPOND TO SOME OF THE- OPTIONS
THAT- LEGISLATIVE ANALYST IT'S
GIVEN US. AND YOUR FIRST POINT I
WOULD I WOULD DEFER TO FINANCING
THE OUT YOUR FUND CONDITION- THE
ISSUE. AND THEN THE SECOND ISSUE
OF- MISTER BROWN'S COMMENTS- WE
AGREE WITH WE'RE WE AGREE WITH
TWO OF THEM AND WE AND WE
DISAGREE WITH ONE OF THEM- WE
THINK IS RIGHT AND CPI AND- AND-
BEHIND THE METER- BUT WE THINK
AGAIN. HAVING THAT FLEXIBILITY
TO MAKE THE UPWARD ADJUSTMENT IF
WE NEED TO IS THAT THE THIRD
PART THAT MAKES THIS A DURABLE
SOLUTION. OKAY THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. I'M HAPPY JUST TO
RESPOND TO THE QUESTION THAT WAS
DEFERRED TO ME- SOME OF THAT
ADDITIONAL STATEMENTS- AS TO
UNDERSTAND THAT REQUEST WE
GENERALLY DON'T PROVIDE OUT YOUR
PHONE CONDITION STATEMENTS BUT
HAVE- WHEN REQUIRED BY
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
WE WILL- LOOK TO TRY AND ADDRESS
THAT CONCERN BY- THE LEGISLATURE
IN TRYING TO PROVIDE SOMETHING
AND- THAT'S RESPONSIVE-
GENERALLY WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT-
WHEN WE'RE PROJECTING INSOLVENCY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE IS JUST
A FLAT BINDING OF EXPENDITURES
AND REVENUES- AND THAT BRINGS US
TO INSOLVENCY BY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE BUT HAPPY TO
PROVIDE. SOMETHING THAT'S
RESPONSIVE THAT YOU CAN LOOK AT
SO. THANK YOU. MISTER BENNETT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AB I THINK
CHAIR BLOOM COVERED THE CPI
ISSUES VERY WELL SO I DON'T NEED
TO SPEND MORE TIME ON THAT- I
THINK PARTICULAR HIS QUESTION
ABOUT TRYING TO EXPAND THE SO WE
HAVE AS MANY PROGRAMS AS
POSSIBLE COVERED WITH THE WITH
THE CPI- OF IT IN GENERAL- I
RESPECTFULLY- THE DILIGENCE OF
THE L. A. IN TERMS OF SAYING DO
WE REALLY NEED TO DO THIS RIGHT
NOW. CENTER AT THE SAME TIME WE
HAVE- THIS. WE HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THIS AT HIM TO
TRY TO DRESSES FOR ME THE
TENSION. THAT I LIKE TO HAVE
THAT THE RIGHT BALANCE ON THIS
AND NOT HAVE THE DEPARTMENT FEEL
LIKE THEY'RE BUDGET IS. SO
GENEROUS THAT THEY DON'T FEEL
THE CONSTANT- INCENTIVE TO DO
THINGS LIKE WHAT YOU DID WAS
YOUR- PHONE SYSTEM- AND SAVE TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS- AT AT
THE SAME TIME. WE WANT C. E. C.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK WE REALLY ALL NEED TO DO
IS ARE AGENCIES NEED TO THINK
MORE PROACTIVELY. AND PLAN
AHEAD- WE JUST HAD SOME PRETTY.
SHOCKING THE NEWS COMING OUT
ABOUT WHERE WE'RE GOING TO BE
WITH HER READ TO IN THE FUTURE-
AND SO- HI BUT WANT US TO BE IF
WE IF WE WANT TO BE PROACTIVE
FIGHT I DON'T WANT TO HAVE THIS
ISSUE OF THE BUDGET CONSTRAINT
CONSTANTLY SORT OF GETTING IN
THE WAY OF THAT SO. I WITH THAT
I'D BE SUPPORTIVE OF MOVING
FORWARD AT THIS POINT IN TIME-
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT WE DO
CONSTANTLY GET THOSE.
PROJECTIONS AL SO THAT WE DON'T
MAKE THIS A BATTLE BETWEEN THE
L. A- TRYING TO GET THE
INFORMATION AND AN
ADMINISTRATION HAVING THE
INFORMATION BUT INSTEAD. HAVE
THE SENSE THAT THOSE LONG TERM
PROJECTIONS IF THAT'S WHAT THE
YOU KNOW HELPS L. A. IN TERMS OF
DOING THEIR ANALYSIS. AT THAT
WOULD HAPPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. SO OAK- ONE FOLLOW UP QUESTION
ON THE- AT TELEPHONE SYSTEM
SAVINGS WHICH IT. AT FIVE VERY
INTERESTING A FIVE I'M A NEW
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC. AND I WANT
TO REACH THE CC. WHAT TURK- I IT
TASTES SOON THE SAME PHONE
NUMBER YOU'VE ALWAYS HAD IS
AVAILABLE WHERE DOES THAT GO HOW
DOES THAT ALL WORK SO WE'VE GOT
THREE- THREE WAYS TO REACH FOLKS
BY PHONE THE FIRST IS WEEK WE
DID SAVE A COUPLE OF LINES I
THINK WE SAVE TWO OR THREE.
TOTAL LINES OUT OF SEVEN
HUNDRED- SO THAT'S ONE WIN SO
THERE'S A THERE'S A MAIN NUMBER-
AND THEN SECOND OF ALL WE HAVE
WE'VE WE'VE HISTORICALLY HAD
SMARTPHONES FOR. SENIOR FOLKS
WHO TRAVEL AND OTHERWISE REALLY
BENEFIT BY HAVING- THAT KIND OF
A PHONE AND EVERYBODY ELSE HAS A
PHONE WITH A NUMBER- AND SOIT'S
IT IT'S TRANSPARENT ANYBODY ON
THE OUTSIDE WHETHER THEY'RE
CALLING ON A CELLPHONE OR
LANDLINE SO. IT THERE HAS BEEN
NO MATERIAL CHANGE. BUT A AGAIN
IF- IF SOMEBODY CAN YOU JUST
WALK ME THROUGH IT- HOW HOW THE
STRUCTURE WORKS FOR THE SYSTEM
WORKS. IF IF I WERE A MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC WANTED TO CALL IN AND
SAY I REACH YOUR OFFICE YEP-
THAT CALL COMES IN. AND THAT
GOES TO A- ESSENTIALLY A
LANDLINE OR VOIP RIGHT- BUT TYPE
OF SET UP AND THEN WHATWHAT
HAPPENS SO IT IT ROTORS OVER TO-
MY COLLEAGUES WHO WHO GETS ALL
THOSE CALLS AND- SHE GENERALLY
ANSWERS THEM IF HE'S NOT THERE
IT GOES TO- IT. BECAUSE WHO
VOICEMAIL AND THEIR CHECKED
DAILY- MULTIPLE TIMES DAILY AND
SO THERE'S WE'RE- VERY
RESPONSIVE THAT WAY. AND THAT
SYSTEM IS WORKING FOR- OFFERED A
PART YEAH SO FAR SO GOOD IT'S
BEEN GREAT. SO IF FIVE- HOW DOES
THE- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
JUST STRUCTURALLY WITH AND- THAT
THE STATE GOVERNMENT OF YOUR
HAVING A GREAT EXPERIENCE WITH
THAT- HOW DO WE TRANSLATE THAT
INTO ADOPTION OTHER AGENCIES HOW
DOES THAT HAPPEN. BY PROMINENT
THE BEST PERSON TO ASK BUT WE'D
BE HAPPY TO SHARE OUR EXPERIENCE
ZERO F. AS YEAH UNFORTUNATELY I
DON'T RESPONSIBLE THAT KIND OF
HAPPY TAKE THAT BACK- YOU KNOW
IT IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT
YOU'RE ADOPTING- SOMETHING THAT
MIGHT BE CONSIDERED A BEST
PRACTICE. HOW DO WE- EXPAND THAT
TO OTHER DEPARTMENTS THAT MIGHT
BENEFIT FROM THAT- ACHIEVE COST
SAVINGS- IT IS IN THE NATURE OF
BUREAUCRACIES TO- CONTINUE TO DO
THINGS YEAR AFTER YEAR- EVEN AS
TECHNOLOGY ADVANCES WE'VE HAD
SOME PROBLEMS- WITH OUR AND I
THINK THAT THERE'S A- CERTAINLY
A LOT OF RESPONSIBILITY TO GO
AROUND- BUT WE'VE HAD SOME
FAILINGS BECAUSE OF FAILURE TO
ADOPT- TECHNOLOGY- HAVING A-
SYSTEM. IN PLACE THAT ALLOWS
EVERYONE TO SHARE SUCCESSES AND
CHALLENGES- WITH. CERTAINLY BE
USEFUL I WOULD. ASSEMBLY
BENNETT'S POINT IS WELL. AND WE
HAVE BEEN VERY FRUGAL FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS- WE HAVE. GONE
THROUGH THE COUCH CUSHIONS YOU
KNOW LOOKING FOR EVERY POSSIBLE
PLACE SO THIS WAS A NATURAL
THING FOR US WHEN COLBERT HIT-
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS AND- OUR
STAFF HAVE REALLY ENJOYED IT THE
ABILITY. TO TELEWORK BROADLY AND
HAVE TAKEN TAKEN. GOOD ADVANTAGE
OF IT IN THE METRICS WE HAVE TO
JUDGE- PRODUCTIVITY TO SUGGEST
THAT OUR OUR OUR PRODUCTIVITY
GOING UP RATHER THAN DOWN AS
SOME FOLKS PRE PANDEMIC. THOUGHT
THAT BEING OUT OF THE OFFICE
MIGHT MIGHT MIGHT SUGGEST. RIGHT
BOB I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE INFORMATION IN THE
PRESENTATION BUT- I THANK GOD
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON NOW TO
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES SO
IF YOU. THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
THE- DMB IS TO BE A- REMOTELY.
WE HAVE A GORDON AND CHIEF BY
OFFICER SCOTT WITH THAT BE RIGHT. THE MORNING. WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE YOUR VISUAL OR JUST TO.
RIGHT ARE. OKAY OKAY MORNING-
CAN BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY ARE
WE GOING TO BE WITH A- MISTER
SCOTT. I GUESS THAT'S CORRECT
OKAY DO WE HAVE A DIRECTOR
GORDON AVAILABLE ALSO. YOU CAN
RECOGNITION IS HERE MISTER BLOOM
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MORNING
THAT- GOOD TO HEAR FROM BOTH OF
YOU. YOU MAY BEGIN. OKAY
SICKENING CHAPLAIN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I GET MY NAME IS LEE
SCOTT BUT SERVE OUR MOTOR
VEHICLES WOULD BE TODAY'S
DIRECTOR PEOPLE AND- THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO REST THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. THE PART THAT
HAS SIXTY ON THE AGENDA ABOUT
LIKE PROVIDE A QUICK OVERVIEW
EACH AND I WILL BE HAPPY ANSWER
YOU UP. THE FIRST EVER TO CAP
POLY BUT THE FIRST IS BOARD YEAR
VIDAK PROTECT BUILT ALEVE
REPLACEMENT PROJECT. UBS
REQUESTING EIGHT. THIRTY THREE
FILES FROM THE FUND. TO PUBLIC.
WHAT THE TWO YEAR- EXPIRATION
DATE TO COMPLETE AN ELEVATOR
MODERNIZATION PROJECT FOR THE
DMV HEADQUARTERS. HERE ON THE
CAMPUS HERE IN SACRAMENTO. AT
THIS CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECT WILL MODERNIZE ELEVEN H.
ELEVATORS A ONE BILL CHAIR STAIR
CLIMBER. AT THE END OF THE
RELATED ELEVATOR MACHINERY UNDER
CONTROLS IN BOTH THE
HEADQUARTERS EAST WHICH IS ABOUT
SIXTY YEARS OLD AND THE BUILDING
CLASS WHICH IS ABOUT SEVENTY
YEARS OLD. I CAN'T I CAN'T ON
THE REST OF YOUR ANY QUESTIONS.
I WILL HOLD QUESTIONS TILL THE
END OF YOUR PRESENTATION. SO
CONNECT ANYONE PLEASE UP THE
NEXT REQUEST IS FOR THE EL
CENTRO BRAWLEY FIELD OFFICE
REPLACEMENT A COMMERCIAL DRIVE-
ATTACHED LETTER. DOT IS
REQUESTING A ROUGHLY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL
FUND IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE TO FUND THE